mais messieurs bonsoir c'est le jour
même du 50e anniversaire de l'arrivée
d'hitler au pouvoir en allemagne que
l'histoire la plus noire de ce xxème
siècle frappe à nouveau à la porte de
nos souvenirs
en plusieurs occasions nous l'avons vu
tout au long de la semaine et
aujourd'hui plusieurs fantôme s'agite à
nouveau parmi lesquels celui d'un homme
que vous n'avez jamais entendu parler et
qui pour la première fois va s'exprimer
devant une caméra
il s'agit de klaus altmann qui ne nie
plus ce soir avoir été le klaus barbie
qui a arrêté jean moulin mais arrêtez
seulement va nous dire barbie avec un
aplomb très cynique je n'ai appris sa
mort que 20 ans plus tard dans ce
document que nous envoie de la page
jean-claude criton vous allez voir
comment de sa prison bolivienne le
criminel de guerre balaie le passé
comment même ils s'indignent du sort on
lui réserve aujourd'hui
pour rappel qu'il est menacé une
extradition imminente vers l'allemagne
et pardon dès à présent pour la qualité
médiocre de l'image tournée l'a sauvé
regardez tout père qui a perdu son fils
j'ai perdu mon fils dé ma femme sur la
durée d'un an et demi et on voit
maintenant la télévision dans l'épreuve
à gants de l'étang de ma femme et de mon
fils c'est un choc pour moi un homme
nommé risque mérite pas je ne conçois
pas ces gens je ne vois pas pourquoi ces
gens si peu de respect pour le genre
humain pour la mort et surtout prête au
jeu
dites moi vous mentionnez le respect à
la mort mais dites-moi devriez vous
souvenir des accusations que l'on vous
fait non je sais pas la même chose je
veux parler moi du respect des tombes
tout ce que l'on me ce dont on m'accuse
c'était la guerre dites moi de l'autre
côté est ce qu'on n'a pas tué aussi oui
bonjour je vous comprends mais c'était
la guerre c'était le maquis vous savez
ici vous en avait fait l'expérience de
la guérilla bon qu'est-ce qui a fait la
remet ici et là reconnus comme
combattants la guérilla non mais
supposons dans le cas des français qui
était en train de défendre leur patrie
vous considérez que ça c'était une
guérilla ok il mais bien entendu c'est
une guerre de guérilla c'était un maquis
parce que la france était occupée mais
elle avait signé un armistice s'était
engagé à ne pas lutter contre les
allemands c'était donc une convention de
la guerre et les maquisards aller contre
les conventions de genève et de la civil
ne doit pas tuer un homme en uniforme
s'ils ont constitué leur maquis ça
c'était le problème est alors le
gouvernement allemand
c'est à dire c'est l occupation
militaire en france a dû se défendre
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui au
salvador en hand ou de race en
afghanistan dites moi maintenant voici
une question
est ce que vous avez eu quelque chose à
voir avec la mort de jean moulin non
avec la mort de jean moulin non oui avec
sa capture oui et bien entendu non avec
sa mort parce que moi j'ai remis jean
mollet j'ai remis jean-moulin à paris et
dites moi comment il ya eu mort mais je
ne sais pas ce n'est qu'en 1965 ici à la
passe dans une un article de paris match
que j'ai appris la mort de jean moulin
on avait trouvé l'amour
et en lisant l'article de paris match
j'ai appris j'ai appris sa mort sous mes
mains il n'est pas mort de mes mains